I'm so fascinated by animals and
just animal life and adaptation.
I think it's one of the more interesting
things about this planet definitely is
these weird organisms that are
trying to figure out their way to,
to survival,
you know,
and then we're responding and moving and
changing and we're always finding new
ones. Like I found a fucking
snake. I posted it up on um,
on Twitter like a week or so ago.
A snake that has a tail that
looks like a fake spider.
Have you seen that fucking thing?
I'm not sure.
What do you know the species of it? I
know the species. I think it's from,
I think it's from Iran and
its a rattle snake. Yeah.
Scale scaled pit viper. Is that it? Yeah.
So Viper not allow snake born Viper Viper.
If you seen that thing.
I know what they are.
Yeah it's incredible.
It looks like a spider and it tricks
birds into coming down and try to snatch
the spider. Here we go.
The Iranians spider,
that viper spider tailed
viper like look at its tail.
That is crazy. I mean, I'm looking at
that in a video and it looks like a bug,
right?
And so this thing moves its tail and it
perfectly blends into the rock around it.
Like look at that and that amount
of camouflage and adaptation.
Like how does that happen?
It's incredible. This boom,
oh, got you bitch done Zo, the birds.
Like what was that? That almost got me.
Yeah, that's insane. What an adaptation.
I mean like you see the Angler fish,
that's a very bizarre adaptation as well.
Same thing just out of the head.
Yeah, I, it's, it's unbelievable.
I mean the fact that creatures
can create that without, you know,
it's not like they're doing
it knowingly, right. Was some,
some handful of snakes at one time started
wagging their tail and realizing the
birds came in and then over generational
time does tail evolved little spikes
and little things and all of a sudden
you have this whole population of animals
that looked like that same. What is it?
How the fuck does that happen? I mean,
how does something grow?
Something like that allure grows a
lure off of its head and he's like,
hey look, it's something for you. No,
you want to eat it. Look at the outline.
Oh my God, that's got a
worm. That'd be the thing.
Literally has like a fishing worm,
like a bass worm.
I mean it's,
it's so amazing.
All of this adaptation and all of these
look at that fucking monster with a
light growing and it's got
a flashlight on its head,
but just it's easy how much adaptation
there is and how all these things sort of
work together,
right?
Like there's the bacteria and the fungi
and the plant life and the animal life
and the predators and the prey
and it all sort of works together.
And when something doesn't work, it just
sort of drops off. And then the, the,
the system sort of resets itself in a
new order. I mean, to me there is no,
you saying it's one of the
most fascinating things to me.
There is nothing more fascinating. Like
I'm, you know, I'm obsessed with it.
I live for it because I
find it so interesting.
Now when you study
these things and you do,
do you ever try to think like
how the fuck that happen?
Like if you see that
that spider tailed snake,
is there anyone that has like an
idea like that this was, you know,
this was just a lucky break that this
one snake had a freaky tail and then he
got the fuck a lot does. He ate a lot
of birds. The idea, man, you just,
I swear to God, you just summed
it up like that is the idea.
W one or two or three snakes
kind of got this adaptation,
just a random random genetic sequencing
that led to maybe a white watch on the
tail. Something unique, not seem like that
though. It seems like they fashioned it,
but over time over it they did,
but over millennia,
right over thousands or tens of thousands
or hundreds of thousands of years.
The one what happened was say there's two
snakes with a white spot on their tail.
Then they have a baby and it
has little bit of deformation.
Write a little thing sticking out.
Then that snake all of a sudden catches
more birds than the rest of the snakes.
That snake now reproduces offspring
and its offspring that has a little bit
bigger of a spike,
catches more birds.
And so those become the prized
animals to reproduce with,
to continue the gene pool. And so
that's what happens. It keeps evolving.
It's like a peacock,
right?
But this crazy big tail that
it's attracting mates with,
it's not useful to the bird.
You know,
that's entirely made for showmanship
for peacocking if you will.
And it over generational time. It gets
bigger and crazier and more elaborate,
more colorful,
and the females literally flock to them.
And that's the animal that continues on.
What I really wish there was a way,
and maybe there will be some time in the
future where they're going to be able
to show you with like some sort
of a super computer sequencing.
Would they be able to look at the
DNA of this thing and say, oh,
this is the exact progression,
right?
This is what it started off with
and this is what it became, right?
This is how some sketchy looking forest
chicken became a peacock. Totally.
You know,
this is how some freaky snake became
perfectly adapted to its environment.
I mean, that thing looks exactly like the
rock that it sits on. It's perfect. Yeah.
It is incredible. Like I would, I'm like
you, I'd love to know who patient zero is.
Who's the, who's the first one. Yeah.
Because stupid people like may
look at that and they'd go, okay,
well that's gotta be a plan that's got
to just something as a higher power.
This is something that like, is looking
after these things and making them,
making them evolve this way.
Right, right. It's, I mean,
it's, it's super interesting.